we've talked about pascal
what happened in nottingham
what happened in nottingham well there
we were
at the end of the 1960s
turn of the 70s i had been appointed to
do
computer appreciation lectures for
arts professors and lecturers and so on
i did a little bit of programming and i
did it in level 60.
algo60 was also what we used because
at that time we were just a little
computer
group within the maths department and
the other lecture involved was andy
walker
uh who well
we both agreed he knew a lot more about
the alternatives than i did
we could see pascal was definitely a
contender
but we also knew they were doing this
alcohol 68
and the attraction at the time although
it wasn't really an attraction we soon
realized was that
algol 68 had a
two level grammar so it wasn't
just bacchus now a specification which
was standard
after algol 60. album 68 took the view
that the way you could gain a lot more
power
was not just to write down by hand
your bnf specification but to have a
master super all
action extra program at the top that
generated the bnf from other
considerations
the efforts of two-level grammars to
lead to a
new way of looking at things appeal to
only a very narrow minority what we were
concerned with
is how did it compare with pascal in
terms of the facilities it would be
offering
was it a suitable language to be given
to computer science undergrads and
specialist postgrads and our view was
yes it was
next question i can't emphasize this
strongly enough but i said it i think in
the in the pascal
video if we're going to teach this are
the compilers any good
because we're going to have you know 50
60 undergrads
wanting to do courseworks with this it's
no good if the compiler's flaky it's got
to be robust
got to have good diagnostics you've got
to be able to teach with it
we could see good compilers being
developed with pascal
and i said to andy but what about algol
68. he said dave you won't believe this
but there is
a bunch of really talented computer
scientists
at the royal radar establishment in
melvin it sounded stupid at the time and
this was a bit before we ever got to
hear about bell labs
that was weird enough you know a secret
bunch of excellent computer scientists
buried inside a
research department for a telephone
company here were some extra
super computer scientists not so many of
them but buried in a radar establishment
and these people are
really competent they have a good track
record and he said you know
even now i mean i was talking about
1970. he said even in 1968
as it was announced they had their
implementation working
i said andy right so in principle it's
fine but here we are
stuck on an icl19 we do not have an ibm
no problem they because they are a uk
research establishment have also been
stiffed with icl hardware
like it or not oh i said well that will
certainly help
if we're all on the same machine so we
got to know them at malvin very
well indeed and rightly they were
celebrated for their
implementation of this album 68. what
did it do
that helped first of all it came up with
an idea of
types well i'll call them types they had
they preferred the in phrase of modes
but i won't call them that because i'll
just confuse you
types they were dead keen on types and
what algol 68 could do
you know if you had an integer it could
now be called an end you could
abbreviate it
but what about the place in memory that
holds your integer
that's got an address but we don't talk
about address we say
it refers to the integer it's where the
integer is stored
so that was taken up everybody like that
oh
it's the end but this place is stored
it's got an address
and that address is a referent it refers
you to where the integer is
you see and then if you get a pointer to
that box that's a pointer to a pointer
and the thing becomes a ref referent and
in the end you sound like a barking dog
you know
so i had this ref reference
and i decided that i wanted to singly
dereference it and not
to doubly de-reference it right down to
the basic end
as the circumstance would seem to imply
so do you know what i did i use the cast
where you pour your hot metal into a
mold and it comes out in the shape you
want it
and i said i'm going to cast it down
just to to reference not all the way
back down to it
all this kind of stuff andy reassured me
quite rightly he said
it does do bites and it does do bits
and all this kind of stuff in your
pascal computer
you can't get down to the big level
manipulation the implementation team at
malvin could use i think they did their
algol 60
to implement algol 68.
they pretty well got their compiler
working on the day the report
was released because of course they were
on the inside track they knew what was
going on
there were a few restrictions on it it
was what's called a single pass compiler
for speed
and that meant sometimes declaring your
structures was a bit awkward
and they had banned certain things that
were appearing in algol 68
that they thought would be expensive to
do it was called algal 68r and i think
our men
restricted andy and i we were very happy
with it we could make a success
but because you're going to ask me
surely it's all right for hardcore
computer scientists
to be casting ref reference down to
reference
how do mere mortals cope with that and
we were very alive to the mere mortals
we weren't just doing hardcore computer
scientists
we were involved in outreach masters
courses
which wanted a bit of programming
towards
making this be a digital business person
or
being on a programming team in a
commercial environment and i think we
both agreed
that a good choice for the absolute
non-specialist but it wouldn't scare
them too much would be pascal
so we did actually run both we ran
pascal for many years i think in our
so-called conversion master's degrees
but we kept algol 68 for the hardcore
stuff was that something you could do
relatively straightforwardly
from an infrastructure point of view
because i'm not talking about pcs on
every desk at this area
no fortunately with the algol 68r
compilers we could have people feeding
in
algol 68 jobs on cards into the 1906a
but equally icl had their own pascal
compiler
one way or another there were good
enough compilers yes i mean we were
teaching
pascal i think into the early 90s
we knew that coming up on the rails
alongside of course
was that c from the mid to late 70s
almost was getting better
and better c has got input from algol
algol 68 and also but principally from
bcpl
and guess what two of the people who
designed bcpl were also on the alcohol
60 committee
basically saying it's not quite the way
to do it bcpl is a lot better and all
this kind of stuff
because of that rallying point way back
of algol 60
it you could transfer between these
dialects
fairly easily you probably had
theological opinions about the right and
just the way forward and you deprecated
all of the other approaches but
nevertheless you knew you were basically
in the same playground
but you were just making different
decisions because of the different
uh you know cleontel involved i think
too
one of the things that does need to be
said and it brought it home to andy and
me
is that the implementation team at
malvin for
alpha 68r was ian curry john morrison
and susan bond ian and john i think were
the driving force behind coral 66 their
early adventure
but uh sue bond was an absolutely vital
member of that team for algol 68.
she was an absolute rock of that team
gets under appreciated because she
suffered from what we've referred to
i think obliquely in these lectures
started at bletchley park
the joan clark effect joan clark was a
highly qualified mathematician
studied at cambridge with alan turing
alan turing wanted her on his team at
bletchley park
big problem they couldn't pay her enough
because she was a woman and cryptography
post was for men only
so they had to get round it by
saying that she was a linguist by
reclassifying her they could get her the
right money i think a similar thing
happened with subon
the only way she could make further
progress was to become more of an
administrator
which she did and she made a very
successful career for herself
here's just a moment when we should be
celebrating our women computer
scientists
they were absolutely equal colleagues
and
you know deserve to get a lot more
respect than they do even now
john backers and peter nauer who were on
the huggle 60 defining committee backus
was famous as one of the big inventors
of fortran
pete's now a very famous european
computer scientist
so at that time what will happen to any
system that is using this way to
represent time
is that one sec